[Musique]
ballersdorf 9 heures du matin fait
maison débute aujourd'hui sa rénovation
énergétique à la manoeuvre l'entreprise
air energy une société spécialisée dans
la mise en oeuvre d' enveloppe basse
consommation de quoi améliorer
grandement le bilan énergétique de cette
maison ancienne sur cette maison on a
donc l'objectif de passer la maison qui
est en classe g à une classe b voire à
c'est-à-dire à diviser entre 4 et 10
sont besoins énergétiques
l'idée au final c'est que le petit poêle
à bois qui servait d'appoint pour faire
une petite raquette le soir
avec les amis voir le feu flambée bas
que ça puisse devenir le chauffage
principal avec une consommation
d'environ une bûche de bois par jour le
plus proposé par l'artisan utilisé
principalement des matériaux biosourcés
d'origine animale ou végétale s'est
produit naturel présente l'avantagé
d'être peu énergivores pour leur
production
recyclable est aussi performant que ceux
utilisés traditionnellement du prix du
bio sourcés effectivement sondés
d'excédent isolant qui ont plusieurs
forces et caractéristiques qui les
différencie des traditionnels qui sont
le polystyrène polyuréthane la laine de
roche de r ces produits notamment un
bilan carbone qui est très intéressant
certaines propriétés thermiques qui sont
plus intéressante que les produits
traditionnels notamment en termes de
stockage d'énergie puisque si on veut
schématiser la résistance thermique
c'est un peu la vitesse de pointe du
coureur mais l'endurance c'est un peu le
stockage thermique et donc effectivement
quand on a les deux on est sur le podium
quand on a pas et deux c'est plus
difficile septembre dernier le conseil
départemental du haut rhin organisait
une table ronde des acteurs du logement
et de la rénovation énergétique
objectif la mise en place du futur
programme d'intérêt général de
transition énergétique
six ateliers étaient organisés au coeur
des discussions les questions de
précarité énergétique et le
développement durable nous avons des
gens au niveau des départements un pig
habiter mieux pour inciter les ménages
les plus modestes donc à rénover leur
énergie ça sert pour une question
environnementale mais c'est surtout
aussi pour pour que la facture
énergétique de ce2 ce2 ces ménages
modestes soient réduites
aujourd'hui le plan d'intérêt général
qu'on lance et un plomb d'interdire à
nouveau il est basée sur serveur on
l'appelle piqueté eux donc transition
énergétique
la différence entre le pid les pigistes
et celui là c'est que celui là on y
glisse que les matériaux utilisés soient
des matériaux écologiques naturels bio
sourcés dominique rue de l'air
participer aux ateliers organisés par le
département
pour l'artisan cette initiative va dans
le bon sens l'utilisation de produits
biosourcés dans la rénovation
énergétique reste pour l'heure trop
méconnu du grand public faire la
rénovation énergétique avec des
matériaux traditionnels
c'est un peu un non sens puisqu'on
utilise des matériaux énergie leur
départ pour faire des économies
d'énergie donc on ne fait que déplacer
le problème qu'il faut utiliser des
produits et des techniques sobrena erj
éthiquement dont l'analyse du cycle de
vie et court et c'est pour ça que
rénover l'ancien c'est vraiment avec des
produits bio sourcés c'est vraiment
l'idéal de ce qu'on pourrait faire
maintenant on peut faire exactement la
même chose le neuf il n'y a pas de
raison qu'un bâtiment performant dans le
neuf ne tiennent pas compte du bilan
carbone ou du bilan analyse de cycle de
vie des matériaux qui le composent
clairement si on veut agir de manière
pertinente et efficace sur bâtiment qui
est quand même le plus gros poste de
consommation énergétique et d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
eh bien il faut agir sur la manière dont
on le construit et dont on l'isolé au
travers de ce programme d'intérêt
général le conseil départemental espère
développer toute une filiale locale
ainsi par le biais ted la rénovation
énergétique pour les plus modestes
outre l'environnement le département
espère avoir un impact positif sur
l'économie du territoire
ça permettra de mettre en place des
filières pour faire mais également pour
produire des matériaux d'isolation etc
nous savons faire donc une filière du
made in elsass de matériaux d'isolation
d'entreprises alsaciennes de de mise en
oeuvre et bien sûr un parka à rénover et
à conforter par rapport donc à
l'isolation permettant de faire des
économies d'énergie
le programme d'intérêt général de
transition énergétique prend place dans
un plan beaucoup plus large celui des
réflexions sur l'avenir du territoire de
fessenheim en effet le conseil
départemental souhaite faire du jour un
modèle de transition énergétique et
s'appuyer sur les nouvelles filières
écologiques pour redynamiser l'économie
de ce territoire
nous passons à la phase de
reconstruction de ce territoire sur le
plan économique et écologique et on
s'inscrit dans la transition énergétique
de ce territoire et de l'ensemble du
département du haut rhin
le projet de territoire de fessenheim va
pratiquement jusqu'à mulhouse ou colmar
et début l'air donc c'est tout ce
territoire est impacté par la fermeture
de fessenheim et donc c'est de mettre en
ligne l'ensemble des acteurs permettant
de la rénovation énergétique mais aussi
de mettre en place une filière
d'excellence par rapport à toute cette
politique pour l'heure encore au stade
des réflexions préliminaires
le nouveau programme d'intérêt général
passera en face de co-construction en
2021 pour une mise en place dans le
courant de cette année
au travers de ce projet le département
espère créer un modèle qui inspirera
d'autres collectivités